so jetzt kommen wir zum großen
kernkraftstreit in der ampelregierung
und der hat diese beiden Gesichter nicht
unsere beiden sondern die von Robert
Habig und Geschichten oh ja sehr
schlecht gelaunt habe der ist ja nun
gegen die Laufzeitverlängerung der drei
noch laufenden Kernkraftwerke und
Lindner der ist dafür der FDP-Minister
macht ordentlich Druck auf den grünen
Habeck ja jetzt der Countdown in diesem
regierungsstreit heute Abend wieder mal
ein krisenstreitgipfel mit dem Kanzler
mit energieborsten und natürlich mit den
beiden selbst darüber sprechen wir jetzt
mit dem Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer der Unionsfraktion also
der Opposition Thorsten frei hierbei
Bild live guten Tag Herr frei so die
erste Frage die wir ihnen erstmal
stellen wollten welches Team sind sie
denn eigentlich Team Lindner oder Team
Habeck
wir gehören zum Team der Vernunft und
die Vernunft ist hier eher auf der Seite
des Finanzministers weil er sehr
deutlich darauf hinweist dass man auf
einen angebotsschock eben auch mit einer
Kapazitätsausweitung reagieren muss und
deswegen ist es vernünftig in dieser
Situation alles auf den Markt zu werfen
was geht dazu gehört Biomasse dazu
gehört vieles andere dazu gehört aber
eben auch Kernenergie wir haben
Berechnungen beispielsweise der
Wirtschaftsweisen Krim die eindeutig
belegt dass das nicht nur ökologisch
sinnvoll ist sondern dass man damit auch
die Preise um etwa 12% senken kann und
deshalb ist es ein Gebot der Vernunft
wir können uns die alte grüne Ideologie
hier schlicht nicht leisten die sprechen
Sie an und Sie wissen ja ganz genau dass
der Robert Habeck ein ziemlich dickes
Problem eigentlich am Hals hat ne mit
der Biografie seiner Partei die wird man
ja nicht so schnell los der hat ein
riesen Ärger in seinem Laden wenn er
plötzlich UMF in der Regierung und
plötzlich für die lange
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
ist wie würden sie in so einer Situation
aus umgehen mit den eigenen
Parteikollegen
also zunächst einmal muss vollkommen
klar sein es geht um Deutschland und es
geht um die Menschen in unserem Land und
dafür ist alles zu tun und es geht nicht
um Grüne Partei Befindlichkeiten das
kann nicht im Mittelpunkt unserer Sorge
stehen und das zweite ist auch wir
möchten nicht den Ausstieg aus dem
Ausstieg sondern wir möchten dass wir in
dieser existenziellen Situation dieser
großen Herausforderung angemessen und
vernünftig reagieren deshalb ist unser
Vorschlag dass die drei noch am Netz
befindlichen
Kraftwerke bis in das Jahr 2024 laufen
denn wir wissen ja heute schon das hat
im übrigen auch die von der
Bundesregierung eingesetzte
Expertenkommission gesagt dass der
Winter 23 24 sicherlich noch sehr viel
herausfordernder wird als der kommende
und deshalb ist es ein Gebot der
Vernunft jetzt in dieser Situation auch
das Angebot zu weiten
gut man muss sagen in der Politik wenn
sie um die Realpolitik geht da muss man
eben Kompromisse machen auf einen
Kompromiss wird es in dieser Frage
wahrscheinlich am Ende auch hinauslaufen
was würden Sie denn eintauschen für eine
Verlängerung der Laufzeit vielleicht ein
Tempolimit ähnliches
ich glaube das macht keinen Sinn zwei
völlig unterschiedliche Themen
miteinander
auszuspielen es ist ja im Grunde
genommen ein Kompromiss wenn Sie sich
erinnern die FDP insbesondere Herr
Lindner hat ja auch schon vorgeschlagen
gehabt dass auch die zwei zuletzt vom
Netz gegangenen Kernkraftwerke wieder
reaktiviert werden sollten das ist ja
vom Tisch wir reden ja über sehr sehr
wenig wir reden über drei Kernkraftwerke
in Deutschland die bis in das
übernächste Jahr laufen sollen und wenn
sie sich mal überlegen dass der gleiche
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt er möchte
auf Kernkraft in Deutschland verzichten
hofft allerdings dass die 56
Kernkraftwerke in Frankreich möglichst
schnell wieder komplett ans Netz gehen
dann kann man diese ganze ideologische
Idiot sehen da passt das eine nicht zum
anderen und deswegen werde ich einfach
dafür dass wir hier zur Vernunft
zurückkehren und in dieser
existenziellen Situation das tun
was man tun muss Greta Thunberg hat ja
diese Woche auch gesagt sie ist für die
Laufzeitverlängerung wenn die schon am
Netz sind dann wird es keinen Sinn
machen die abzuschalten und sie haben
Herz plötzlich entdeckt auch für Greta
Thunberg in der Union sind sie jetzt Fan
von Greta
nein soweit würde ich nicht gehen vor
allen Dingen deshalb nicht weil sie
sozusagen auch die unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen Bedürfnisse nicht in
ihre Erwägungen mit einstellt aber es
ist doch absolut vernünftig und sie
steht da im übrigen auch nicht allein
ich bin davon überzeugt dass auch viele
grüne außerhalb unseres Landes sind ganz
Europa mit großer Verwunderung auf
Deutschland schauen dass wir
schmutzigste Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz
nehmen das ist auch notwendig in dieser
Situation es wird Kohle in Südafrika
beschafft auf der anderen Seite möchte
Harbeck stinkende ölkraftwerke auf den
Meeren laufen lassen das ist im Grunde
genommen die Stromerzeugung die
Energieerzeugung von dritte weltländern
das passt einfach nicht zusammen dann
auf der anderen Seite
CO2-neutrale Kernkraft nicht zu nutzen
obwohl das leicht und unproblematisch
möglich wäre es ist also weder
ökologisch noch ökonomisch vernünftig
was habe die Grünen derzeit tun sagt
Thorsten frei Dankeschön dass Sie sich
die Zeit genommen haben
hierbei Bild live guten Morgen meine
beiden Streithähne Robert Habeck und ihr
Christian Lindner wie würden sie das
Verhältnis der beiden im Moment
beschreiben
es ist eine sachliche und professionelle
Zusammenarbeit das ist eine
Regierungskoalition bei einem Thema wo
unterschiedliche Positionen existieren
liegt es in der Natur der Sache dass der
Mensch sprechen auch intensiv diskutiert
wird gestritten wird müssen Sie schon
betonen dass das eine Regierung gerade
ist das nimmt man ja nicht immer so wahr
es ist eine Regierung allerdings ist es
aus meiner Sicht völlig normal dass man
bei bestimmten Punkten es ist ja eine
Koalition es ist keine Fusion hier sind
drei unterschiedliche Parteien
zusammengekommen die eine Regierung
bilden und bei dem Thema
Laufzeitverlängerung gibt es seit Wochen
Monate wie Sie wissen unterschiedliche
Auffassungen und Position und diese
Position in der Tat sie liegen weit
auseinander aber diese Koalition hat in
der Vergangenheit aber auch bewiesen
dass nach Lang Lang Debatten man immer
in der Lage war gute Lösungen am Ende
des Tages für das Land zu erreichen und
ich bin davon überzeugt dass es auch
hier gelingt wird auf diese Lösung
warten wir jetzt schon relativ lange und
es wird Zeit dass eine kommt wann wird
sie denn jetzt endlich geben
ich gehe fest davon aus dass die
nächsten Stunden die nächsten Tage
entscheidend sein werden denn wir
brauchen ja auch die kommende
Sitzungswoche des Deutschen Bundestages
um auch Entscheidungen herbeizuführen
denn das was wir beschließen wollen das
was wir verändern wollen bedeutet ja
auch eine Veränderung des Atomgesetzes
beispielsweise des Paragraph 7 des
Atomgesetzes das heißt es wird sich
jetzt was tun aber noch einmal es ist
aus meiner Sicht völlig normal dass bei
unterschiedlichen inhaltlichen Position
dass da auch lange Prozesse dazu gehören
ich glaube das ist das wundert ihn ja
ich wundere mich dass sie sich da nicht
durchsetzen können sie haben das ist für
die FDP vielleicht auch nicht so
gewöhnlich wirklich die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung in der Frage mittlerweile
hinter sich und Sie können sich gegen
Robert Habeck nicht durchsetzen wieso
sind sie da zu schwach bisher nein es
ist also damit nicht zu tun ob man zu
stark oder zu schwach ist hier gibt es
unterschiedliche Auffassung sie kennen
die Position der Grünen seit vielen
vielen Jahren sie kennen die Position
der SPD vermutlich auch genau
tendenziell bei den Grünen und wir haben
da eine andere Auffassung wir sind davon
überzeugt dass wir uns sowohl in
Deutschland als auch in Europa derzeit
in einer Krise befinden übrigens es
lohnt sich an der Stelle auch diese
Debatte mal gesamteuropäisch zu
betrachten die Länder der Europäischen
Union wollen gerade in dieser Krise
zusammenstehen und niemand in Europa
kann verstehen dass Deutschland vor dem
Instrument der Laufzeitverlängerung kein
Gebrauch machen wird es ist eine
Notwendigkeit in Deutschland aber es ist
aber eine Frage es ist auch eine Frage
der europäischen Solidarität hier die
drei am Netz verfügbaren Kernkraftwerke
mindestens bis 2024 laufen zu lassen gut
bei der Politik ist es ja immer so wenn
es Streit gibt wenn gezofft wird dann
gibt es am Ende irgendwo einen
Kompromiss was wären sie denn bereit
einzutauschen gegen die
Laufzeitverlängerung Tempolimit zum
Beispiel nein die Debatte kann man so
nicht führen hier geht es um eine
wichtige inhaltliche Frage für die
Zukunft unseres Landes hier geht es um
die Frage der Energiesicherheit und
Energieversorgung übrigens nicht nur im
Herbst und Winter dieses Jahres sondern
auch darüber hinaus denn niemand kann
uns derzeit auch sagen wie lange der
Krieg in der Ukraine dauern wird und
niemand kann uns sagen wie lange wir
diese Energieknappheit diese
Energiekrise haben werden das heißt wir
müssen jetzt alles dafür tun um die
Preise zu senken Preise zu stabilisieren
und die Belastungen für Haushalte
Unternehmen Betriebe zu reduzieren und
ich wir sind ja nicht hier auf einem
Basar nach dem Motto du kriegst das
dafür kriegen wir das hier alle die die
in dieser Koalition sind müssen sich
darüber im Klaren sein in dieser
Situation gilt erst das Land dann die
Partei letzte Frage Herr
FDP-Generalsekretär jetzt haben sie den
Robert Habeck da quasi vor sich sitzen
wie knacken sie den in der Frage der
Laufzeitverlängerung sie kennen den
Typen jetzt mittlerweile lang genug wie
knacken sie den
ich habe mir auf dem Weg hierhin fest
vorgenommen mich nicht locken lassen von
Fragen dieser Art deswegen werde ich das
auch sehr sachlich beantworten ich bin
davon überzeugt dass wir am Ende des
Tages gute Ergebnisse hinbekommen werden
sie haben sich vorher vorgenommen nicht
richtig zu antworten auf die nein ich
habe mir vorgenommen nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein
ich habe bewusst hier sehr sehr sachlich
auf diese hochkomplexe Frage geantwortet
und habe niemanden beleidigt oder
verletzt danke
sich vorher noch mal vornimmt dann habe
ich nicht zu beleidigen damit das
wirklich klappt in der Sendung danke an
den fdp-generativ
[Musik]